this week we will consider the special
case of circular motion the case where
we know that the motion is exactly
constrained to have a circular geometry
this will consist of two parts first we
will consider the kinematics of circular
motion how do we describe the trajectory
velocity and acceleration of a particle
undergoing circular motion we will
consider both the simple case of uniform
circular motion where the object moves
with constant speed and also non uniform
circular motion where the object is
speeding up and or slowing down as a
function of time we will see that a
Cartesian coordinate system proves
awkward for describing circular motion
and instead we will introduce the so
called polar coordinate system in terms
of the radius vector from the origin and
its position angle which provides a much
more elegant description for circular
motion we will then examine the dynamics
of circular motion using Newton's second
law to understand what sorts of forces
are required in order to cause circular
motion in both the uniform and non
uniform cases this will be the first of
several examples we will see in this
course of constrained motion in this
case the constraint is that the object
moves in a circular path